Listen up.
While we're all here,
there are some things
that we ought to figure out
before we rip this place apart.
I feel like I'm genuinely
shocked with how fun
the cast is.
It's really fun.
Our downtime is great.
It wasn't hard. We kind of
liked being around each other.
-It's been really fun. Yeah.
-I've loved it.
We've had a great time.
We have a lot of fun
in between rehearsals.
We all just get the giggles.
A lot.
Especially in group scenes.
There was one scene
where Kathryn
had to do, like,
this big speech.
Is there anyone who objects?
It was, like, quite serious.
A bunch of girls behind me
just got the giggles
-and it was pretty funny.
-We just can't stop laughing.
You'll see us
in the background.
We'll just be laughing
and they're just hilarious.
When it's a sensitive scene...
Somebody clear that table.
...we all come together
and we huddle.
And we just take a couple
deep breaths all together.
And then we all feel
kind of connected
and in sync again.
We play probably about
three games of chess
every night before
going to sleep.
And I've become, like,
a chess master.
Jack Mulhern and I
started a book club.
A lot of other people
joke about it on set
because we're always off
hovered in a corner
over this ancient Greek text.
The first week
before we started,
I had everyone over
and we made dinner.
Me and Alex,
who plays Harry,
have gone and rented
a house,
and we've been having
quite a few parties.
I never went to college,
so I thought I had missed
the chance
for that experience.
But I definitely got it
on this show.
It's been the coolest thing.
Everyone seems very grateful
for being on this production.
It's just such a good...
just good vibes all around.